[Music]
I could not have written ready player 1
if I had not grown up on a steady diet
of Steven Spielberg movies it would have
been a different story or I might not
have written it at all
his work is woven into the fabric of my
life
everybody I think who dreams of making
movies dreams of getting to work with
him it's a dream come true
[Music]
when I read ready player one it was the
most amazing flash-forward and flashback
at the same time I was born in 2025 but
I wish I'd grown up in the 1980s my
Khalid a and Laura like all my heroes I
suddenly saw a future that earned his
client the writer of the book envisioned
it wasn't that far away from what I
think is going to happen someday I live
here in Columbus Ohio in 2045 Columbus
is the fastest-growing city on earth but
it sure doesn't seem like it when you
live in the stacks there's a dystopian
society and the fabric of our economy is
crumbling it's a good time to escape so
virtual reality will be a super drug
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
[Music]
I was very careful with Ernie
collaborating with me every step of the
way to be able to find the movie
narrative inside this dense forest of
Ernie's so found imagination
the Oasis being the ultimate toy box
with all the toys in the world and then
playing that with one of the greatest
filmmakers of all time it results in
just amazing action and such a fun
adventure
[Music]
ernest cline is such a visionary and i
has seen the future before any of us
possibly could even imagine it
you